let's continue our examination of G CDs
and linear combinations and Euclidean
algorithm by examining what's often
called the extended Euclidean algorithm
it's a good name for it it's ancient
name for the dating back to ancient
India is the pulverizer and we will see
what that does in a moment so the
theorem that is the culmination that
we're aiming for is that the GCD of two
numbers is an integer linear combination
of the two numbers that is the GCD of a
and B is simply s a plus TB or S&T are
integers and what the polarizer enables
us to do is give an a and B we can find
SNT in fact we can find s in t virtually
as fish as efficiently as a nucleating
an algorithm is just by performing
Euclidean algorithm and keeping track of
some additional site information as it
progresses
now corollary of this fact is that we
now know that the if we want to
characterize the linear combinations of
a and B they're precisely the multiples
of the GCD of a and B that's because we
know that every factor of both a and B
defines any linear combination of a and
B and therefore the GCD which is a
factor of a and B divides any linear
combination once we know so that means
that that any or linea any linear
combination is a multiple of the GCD of
a and B of course once we know the GCD
of a and B is itself a linear
combination it means that you've got all
of the linear combinations by taking
multiples of the GCD okay how do we get
S&T well the basic idea is that we're
going to find these coefficients by
applying the Euclidean algorithm and as
we go we're going to be calculating
efficient coefficients and eventually
when we're all finished we'll wind up
with the S&T specifically let's remember
the euclidean algorithm starts off with
with a and B and then it has two
registers or numbers x and y that it
keeps updating and the invariant is that
the GCD of the x and y that are being
continually updated by the Euclidean
algorithm it stays the same as always
the GCD of a and B so what we're going
to do is just
keep track of coefficients called them
CDE and F such that the X whatever we're
up to we know how to express as a linear
combination of a and B and the Y that
were whatever Y we're up to we can also
express them as a linear combination of
a and base so we're going to be keeping
track of these four coefficients C D E
and F that have this property this
property is going to be another
invariant of our extended Euclidean
algorithm or pulverizer well how do we
get initial values for a c d e and f
well that's easy at the start X is a and
so C is 1 and D is 0 because a is 1 a
plus zero B similarly y is 0 a plus 1 B
so we know what these values of c d e
and f are at the start of the algorithm
question is how do we update them
well how does Euclidean how does a
uclear work well remember at the next
step the value of x is the old value of
y so if I had the old value of y as ei
plus FB then I clearly have a the next
value of x as the same linear
combination that Y you know that Y had
preview then Y have previously what
about Y next well at the next step the
value of Y is simply the remainder of x
+ y well the remainder of x + y remember
is just X minus the quotient times y
where the quotient is the quotient of X
divided by Y so this is equal to the
remainder of of x + y and that means
that since I have Y since I also have X
expressed as a linear combination this X
minus qy is simply this linear
combination for X minus the quotient
number times the linear combination from
Y well the difference of two linear
combinations is a linear combination so
just combining coefficients what I
discover is that the way to express Y
next as a linear combination of a and B
is just to combine the previous
coefficients C D E and F with the
quotient in this way and that's all
there is to it well let's work out an
example to see how it goes suppose that
a is $8.99 and B is 493 this was a
number that we had previous that we had
previously applied the Euclidean
algorithm to so now what we're doing is
observing I need to I'm going to begin
by calculating the remainder but this
time when calculating the remainder
let's keep track of the quotient so I'm
gonna find the remainder of 899 divided
by 493 its 406 and the quotient is 1
that is 899 is 1 times 493 + 406 what
does that tell me well 406 then is
remember 899 is a and 493 is B we're
tell I'm discovering that the first
remainder 406 is 1 times a plus minus 1
times B so now I have that first
remainder expressed as the desired
linear combination of a and B well
what's next
well now that I've got 406 and 493 I'm
supposed to take the remainder of 493
divided by 406 well that's 87 in fact
493 as a quotient of 1 times 406 plus
eighty seven so that tells me that 87 is
this number minus that number 87 is 493
- 406 yeah well remember 493 is B so 87
is 1 times B minus 1 times 406 but wait
wait wait look up here 406 I know how to
express it as a linear combination of a
and B so let's replace the 406 by 1 a
plus minus 1 B and what I'm gonna wind
up with remember it's a it's a minus
minus so I wind up contributing an A and
an extra B and I wind up with a minus a
plus 2 being said that roughly but the a
is getting negated you can check my
algebra so there we are with the linear
combination expresses the next remainder
87 all right let's continue after this
what we're supposed to do is find the
quotient of 406 by by 87 of and the
remainder so when you divide 406 by 87
you get a quotient of 4 in a remainder
of 58 which means the remainder 58 is
406 minus 4 times
87
but now looking above I have the
coefficients of 406 for a and B and I
have the coefficients for 87 for a and B
here and so I have to multiply those by
4 and I wind up that the way to express
58 in terms of a and B is it's 5a plus
minus 9 B and now next I'm supposed to
find the remainder of of 87 divided by
58 the quotients 1 the remainder is 29
and that means that 29 is 1 times 87
minus 1 times 58 looking back I see how
to express 87 in terms of a and B and 58
in terms of a and B I can just combine
those expressions to wind up with 29 is
-6 times a plus 11 times B next I have
to take the quotient of 58 divided by 29
while the the quotient is 2 but the cool
thing now is the remainder is 0 that's
the stopping condition for the Euclidean
algorithm it means that the answer is 29
there's no remainder anymore so the GCD
of 29 and 0 is 29 the final GCD then we
finished is 29 but look what we got in
the last step I had expressed that GCD
as a linear combination of a and B and
that's the pulverizer I've just figured
out that possible values for s nter
minus 6 and 11 and this is a perfectly
general procedure that will always give
you coefficients S&T that express the
GCD of a and B in terms of a and B now
sometimes it's technically convenient to
be able to control which of the
coefficients are positive and which
negative clearly if you're going to
combine a and B that are both positive
numbers and wind up with a positive
number by with a smaller number by
adding multiples of them one of those
coefficients has to be negative so in
this case we had the coefficient of 89
was minus 6 and the coefficient of B was
11 and suppose
that I wanted though the first
coefficient of a to be the positive
number and the other one to be negative
why how can I do that well there's a
pretty trivial little trick for doing
that's ingenious button but it's
immediately verifiable how do I get a
positive coefficient for $8.99 well
there's a general way to get new a
coefficients okay if you look at minus-6
899 plus eleven 493 if I add any
multiple of 493 to the first coordinate
and I subtract the same multiple of 899
for the second coordinate all I'm doing
is adding 493 times K times 899 to the
first term and I'm subtracting 493 times
899 times K from the second term they
cancel out so this linear combination is
going to be the same as that one it's
gonna be the same GCD but now I'm by
adding in any multiple by the way K
could be positive or negative of 493 I
can make the positive I can make the
first coefficient as big or as small as
I like in particular if I want it to be
positive might as well take the smallest
value of K that works which is one so if
I let K be one I discover that I add 493
to minus 6 I get 487 and I subtract 11 I
subtract 899 from 11 I get minus 8 88
and there we are with another expression
for this time s is 487 and T is minus
888 and the second one is negative and
the first one is positive it's going to
turn out that this little trick will
enable us in a in the next video to come
up with a general solution to the
diehard bucket problem which is fun but
let's finish up the current story and
the remark is that the pulverizer is
really another very efficient algorithm
exactly the way the Euclidean algorithm
is efficient it's basically got the same
number of transitions when you update
the pair X Y to get a new pair Y
remainder of X divided by Y so it's
taking logged twice log to the base 2
number of transitions log to the base
would be transition so it's
exponentially efficient it's working in
the binary the lengthened binary of the
number B of course there's a few more
additions and multiplications per
transition for the extended GCD that
with the pulverizer than the ordinary
Euclidean algorithm so big deal it means
that the number of total arithmetic
operations of adds adds and multiplies
is proportional to the log to the base 2
of B I said here 6 I think it's actually
like 10 but the main thing is it's a
small constant times the log to the base
2 of B the pulverizer is a very
efficient algorithm as well as the
Euclidean algorithm and those are going
to be crucial facts that will build on